Let's get to hatred. Male for the week. Patriot
mail is when, when a professional voiceover
artist interprets the hate mail that I get.
Here's a little bit more information about
hatred, male,
because thoughts and prayers are bullet proof
written by patriots who hate David Pakman
because America and because freedom.
So this week's hatred male, um, it does follow
a common theme from the Patriots, but it's,
it's not as common as just general homophobia
or antisemitism. It has to do with victim
complexes and, uh, being a triggered snowflake.
Take a listen to this.
David Packman is such a fool, flop, a sore
loser. The bottom line is this pack face,
no collusion. So now impeach Dave. Sociopath
Backman. I tell Vladimir I have more flexibility
after the election. Remember that I condemn
all anti-Jewish attacks, but attacks on white
gentiles are the real issue. Jews are gas
lighting,
you know, for a political movement that has
made a big deal out of, uh, not being easily
triggered and not constantly needing people
to provide safe spaces from them. It's amazing
how this movement has grown, which claims
that white gentiles as the hatred that says,
uh, I guess we mean just people who aren't
Jewish, um, uh, have been, uh, sort of really
the victims in the United States in an American
Society for five years, 10 years, 20 years.
I don't know how long, maybe dating all the
way back to the civil rights act of 1964.
You would think that for people who purport
to be these ultimate Alphas of all kinds and
in all ways, they wouldn't be constantly complaining
about how they are actually the victims in
the United States of America. Um, in any case,
you can take hatred, citizen and make it something
good for independent media, by signing up
for a membership on our website using the
coupon code hatred, 40 h, a, t, R, I. O. T,
four zero.
You save 40%. When you use that coupon code
and the hatred it's hated because they realize
the impotence of their hate hatred 40 uh,
on any membership@davidpakman.com slash membership
it'll save you 40%